voilà vous coûtera qu'une action et
pourquoi bien sûr ce que je trouve que
pour une piqûre qui est très facile à
faire ça protège des maladies qui sont
peut-être dangereuse je trouve est
nécessaire de vous faire vacciner contre
le choléra
oui je crois que c'est nous apprend
contre l'hépatite b qui est une enfant
jeune n'est pas utile contre lorient
chez les filles contre la rubéole chez
les garçons j'ai un enfant de 12 ans qui
doit être vacciné
il est hors de question je suis contre
la vaccination obligatoire
chacun est libre de faire ce qu'il veut
[Musique]
on
la vaccination anti porno j'ai déjà
voulu mais j'ai toujours remis mais
maintenant comme c'est obligatoire je me
dis je veux dire est ce cette
application
non je ne laisse pas faire parce que
c'est obligatoire mais j'estime que
c'est une garantie pour les enfants
je suis pour leur activation j'ai deux
enfants
il y en a un qui est déjà vaccinées
l'aude est coopté c'est pour ça que
je trouve qu'on peut laisser les parents
libres de faire ce qu'ils ont à faire
moi j'en ai je ne compte pas les fermes
action
[Musique]
il était passionnant quand 91 donc à
trois injections d'intervalle donc
octobre août septembre et octobre 91 et
mes premiers symptômes sont apparus en
novembre 80
[Musique]
où
je suis pas contre les vaches c'est pas
du tout anti pacs mais je suis contre le
fait que en oblige d'abord la population
vaccinée et comme
se permettent ils sont deux
dans le monde
le prince consort
[Musique]
et marine et technology holdings as to
save lives soit en combinant deux là
bonjour